das weiß glaube ich auch selbst was er
starkes weiß weiß weiß weiß ist dass ich
stark ist aber weiß weiß weiß weiß weiß
weiß ich weiß was wahr ist weiß aber was
weiß weiß weiß macht weiß weiß lang noch
nicht heiß weiß was macht dich heißt das
noch lange nicht heißt
sagte wieder leute was geht ab hier ist
euer cani und wir spielen heute in
münchen minecraft bahro und ich hatte
ich habe schon weil ich 21 scheint kann
ich mich ja der schreck bibi und tina
ich werde mir das gesehen habt ihr keine
ahnung aber sowas ist unser plan ist
nach 889 sekunden aufnahme zeigt ein
bier aus auswahl hg haus aus
bis zum anschlag okay ich würde jetzt
noch da bis zum anschlag und dann bauen
wir brauchen wieder rauszukommen die
mister morgen hatte das lokal nur ein
paar screenshots
da war noch bögen und so was eher
ungewöhnlich aber brauchen wir die
bastille gmbhg hatte ihm keine probleme
während war o 3 wir kleben 80gb von mir
rein gerade der gute bastian kraft
sicher dass dank kraft wenn er das jetzt
schreibe ich ein abfallen heute dank für
80 schreiben würde
doch ernst halter zum haus und übrigens
leute ich kann jetzt auch wieder ein
bisschen mehr zeit der bearbeitung wird
man da ich jetzt wieder zu hause bin und
ich habe sowieso schon nicht am ersten
weg ich habe besprechen wir nachher
ja bis jetzt leider verschlossen in der
höhle hör ich hatte da müssen wir kurz
reinschauen
wir können aber irgendwann mal die für
die nachricht von dagmara buckley
hochladen
nein ich habe so ein fake account
angefragt jetzt kommen wir aber gerade
die einrichtungs weil das wohl die vorne
aller wandel also mich hat ein fake
account von kba angeschrieben und so
voll beleidigt so wir sollten aufhören
so dass öffentlich klärte an sagt ein
kleiner stress macher geschrieben auch
richtig ernst wie dich selbst auch wenn
alles fertig es geht nach oben wie keine
warum ist aber allein private die wahl
auch hier oben ist das echt okay wenn
wir erst jetzt wechseln essen können ich
häng keine luft das wäre schon sehr sehr
keck es wäre doch blöd wenn wir jetzt
einfach beleidigend ein kecker bursche
dass auch eine begleitende lösten
hermann das neue moschino einem alter da
kommen jeder laien fast keck vor
ok ich hab' das da reingesteckt auch
wieder raus
das navi schon hier rechts oder ob
dahinter müsst ihr sein hatte null wir
sind bei x20 wir müssen ihnen denkt aber
wir gehen uns das wort wir gehen da
vorzulegen davor zu bilden zu den ochsen
gehen dabei nicht weiter wir gehen vorne
zu den eichen bier immer ein bisschen
aggressiv also einem kampf bin ich dann
aggressivere von uns beiden und sterben
40 das nächste pause habe ich dass wir
jemand anders aus so ward wasser
mitnehmen hast du dein wasser kann die
msg machen
msg krank besucher genauer als ob er
selber von der seite kommt
alterslos gehen vielleicht finden wir
sie erstens simon bei diesem kleinen see
haben wir aber geschrieben hier ist ja
nur ein einziger segen da ist ein
hexenhaus in der mitte das heißt wir
wissen 100pro wenn wir sehen dass die
man in der nähe ein bitteres abzustauben
aber ein zwei leuten zu einzelnen so
kletterte das um gespielt von braml was
was was rahmen alter 100 er muss 100
dollar was ein cabrio willst du so bist
du was leute so krass aber die
derzeitigen zu zweit hinzu zweiter
weil wir einfach alle live kommentieren
hier alter liveticker du rennst im spot
fucking ernst hey du weißt doch zum
hexen los
ja weil um den spot rumrennen hier
irgendwo hab mir lockt sie uns warum
motto alter jetzt ist hier aber richtig
wie mag es ab ich sterbe so viele ich
will mir jetzt nicht auch noch rumrennen
sterben warum wurde vom ok das heißt
zombies alleine und verbluten ist tot
komplett raus und man sollte einfach das
ist ja hat firmenfeier bekommen hätte
hier ab wo bist du wirst du verstehen
wieso wirst du immer so in sicht hat die
so abgeht alter danke für die info er
werde mir gar nicht aufgefallen so dass
wir jetzt so in so einem großen kreis
aber lasst doch hier dass hier zumindest
die eichener bolliger wir brauchen echte
goldabschnitt applebaum echt man wir
haben 14 gold blöcke alter noch mehr
wirklich kein bock gekürzt werden wie in
der ersten folge beim baum abbauen oder
jemand genau wobei du halt auch so geil
rankommen kann seitdem tut weggefährten
wenn es jetzt angenommen und auch
irgendwie so ein zwei rohrbomben ist
ganz einfach drum kit nun ist einfach
tot direkt ja ich weiß
ok ich stelle mich mal auf dem baum
guck mal was da abgeht gerne die lage
christoph matschie viel arbeit
von christa damals mit ben geguckt von
games alles so poster bei den video des
gibt und bullshit tv schon einfach
christoph krachten zum poster von
christoph krachten er das werde ich mir
sicherlich ein eigenes selbst bekämpfen
kann bekommt wo bist du willst du denn
fragt wo willst du hinter dir da wo wir
die eichen abgebaut haben da bin hier
auch ein bisschen nicht ich bin am
anfang durch seht ihr dann laufen wir
mal alles leute update you next alter wo
er macht auch maschine
wer aber weiß es gut markus weise das
weiß weiß ja wie auch selbst was er
stark ist weiß weiß weiß weiß ist dass
ich stark ins aber weiss weiss weiss
weiss weiss weiss war die meist war
zweitweise weiß weiß aber ich weiß lange
was weiß weiß weiß macht weiß weiß lang
noch nicht heiß weiß was macht dich
heißt macht meist weiß noch lange nicht
heißt korrekt finger fliegen bling bling
bling bling können das weil ich nicht
logisch aber doch das alles weiß was
macht meist weiß nicht heißt wenn es
doch weiß was nicht heißt es ist doch
geil was ich darauf unter der geile der
geile bosse was weiß weiß nicht weiß
macht beispielsweise ohne mit es gibt
niemand alle sind so voll so am locker
so spannung spannende musik als das
alter wald im letzten lauf locker
flockig gerade einen job was lauf lauf
max lauf ja die ist 10 2-lauf maxis
nicht schießt nicht auf ich habe einen
hit gelandet com
und herunter runter runter runter
unteren aber nicht ins wasser will und
kann nicht anders weil du auf dem land
laufen kanzler vom land wer schnell von
max hilfe ich bin hinter die wasser
darauf mich bitte ich war okay sie
schießen schießen muss es nicht das
essen kommt nicht ins wasser
dass du dass es länger dauert für sie
das länger dort für sein alter das sind
meine bros ich bin nicht töten falls es
den maxis schlecht aussehe und dein
leben getan was sie über wasser das die
ganz lange brauchen uns hinterher kommt
ja das ist nicht richtig geschlossen
ok wack ihr alter ich will nicht gegen
dr wechsel für können weil erstens nie
so krass punkten ihren kassen und mega
gut wirklich willkommen
was bei mir hast du klingst du noch ja
ich mag ist die sind ja erst mein kind
so hast du noch ich habe noch drei okay
dann erläutert dass hier ein baum hat
macht es macht mir ein kombi ich glaube
laufens nicht auf die distanzen der egal
herr wiese war einfach weltklasse okay
dass mir jemand wenn und fehle ihr wir
wollen töten aber wir wollen nicht
getötet lernen wollen wir auch nicht
töten natürlich vor allem auf einmal
gekratzt seite wo sind die bamberger
machen dann kann es keine
wir wollten ein bisschen thema und
einfach weil wir es können nein das war
kein apple bekommen alter die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein abruptes 1
zu 200 glaube ich habe ich heute gelesen
ja dieses winzig ich habe einen gold
abgenommen
holzapfel motto lasst mal wieder den
kopf den ich vielleicht hier liegen zwar
in chat holzschwerter entscheidend dem
holzschwert ab
kein plan halte okay wie scrabble
richtig viel aber brauchen wir ähnlich
weil wir haben keine federn breite will
und beckmann
okay aber lasst ihr nun weiteren lass
mal in einem weiteren bogen jetzt um die
zahlung aller siehste da da habe ich
nicht wirklich okay hier ja wir gehen
einfach außen rum und dann gehen wir von
einer anderen seite machen den fahrern
um den berg personen seien weniger und
sohn basti er hätte ich auch nicht allzu
viel lust drauf welche ja gut da dies
richtig klar aber ich denke die werden
schon länger von seinem entwurf auf die
boarder aufpassen denn die schrift auch
ja aber nur nach dem restart abgesagt im
morgen dann werden wir sie spielen
bekommen wenn ich das wird außerhalb
stehen schon mächtig ab max kaninchen
bringen
als ich mal kurz die fakten thriller weg
finden muss sein weiß nicht altern so
war hat das super gemacht die seine
verfolger waren da unten erst wieder
hochgerappelt wasser runter gemacht das
heißt sie konnten die treppe nicht mehr
so schnell hoch in hier ist lava soll
mit dem holen ich habe was du kein habe
einmal so ne psp kälter wurde auch leid
aber ich bin lieber feuerzeug der aber
klar ein lager als auch nicht falsch zu
haben doch so jetzt wieder wieder
richtung wobei wir sollten auch hier mal
wieder im ausland ein bisschen aktiv
sind keine schwarzen wo bist du das und
natürlich den schwarzen wo bist du wo
bist du hier bin ich allein kann das
eichenholz das ist fichtenholz
okay kein schwarz war zeichnen diese
fetten fed träume drunter spinnen dinger
sind so gut wie nie zu reden aber nicht
gegen niederkassel ich auch wir haben
das ist nervig dass wir immer werden
sind ab was war gab es einen fall wo
bist du
dabei befinden da brennen wollen da muss
irgend jemand feuer gesetzt scharaf war
mia farrow carrie bei nacht habe ich es
auch nicht zum boxer oder weihnacht kein
bock weil sich das alter blätterwald
nicht stimmt ist unerheblich aus können
wir keine rückschlüsse ziehen wer
irgendwo war
vielleicht feuerwehr anrufen und fragen
ob die irgendwie kurzschließen können wo
der waldbrand kommt 112 aus 12 was
wollen wir uns über nacht hat wenigstens
noch irgendwo rein bauen wie es mit
würde würden wir besteigen wie
servietten weg lasst es dass das jetzt
wirkt sonst haben wir es schwer später
wieder
ja die sind schon fackeln das heißt sie
war schon jemand bekommt wo bist du
wachst auf deutschlands bahnhöfen und
immer wieder gut was passiert leute
wieder etwas besser alltag wollitz
erfolg überstand leute die nächste folge
gehen wir wieder hoch wenn es wieder
hell ist und dann versuchen wir jemanden
zu bekommen alter wir sind richtig kampf
klar wir wollen nicht gegen krasse teams
kennen ja sehen wie man zunächst bis
morgen